why don't we go next to Gabe from
Louisiana Gabe welcome to the program
hey can you hear me yes
Hey so uh I have a question about uh the
Republican response to the 2022 midterms
okay
so I was
very much scared that many Republicans
would refuse to concede however based on
what I've seen it seems to mainly just
be Carrie Lake unless there's someone
I'm not aware of no it's basically you
have like yeah
but yeah so do you have any idea why
they may have backed off from that do
you think it might be because the see
that you know the Trump candidates
didn't do well so they're trying to
distance themselves or what do you think
it's two things I think it's number one
um they saw the trend and a lot of these
people lost and the idea that it was all
fraud even if
some Republican voters would buy it
seems like a very hard case to make
because a lot of these were individual
State cases that's number one secondly I
think it's that it's now been two years
of trump and people around Trump trying
to overturn the results and it hasn't
worked and if Trump wasn't able to do it
I can't imagine they think they will be
able to succeed so I think it's some of
them recognize the futility of it
okay awesome that very much answers my
question thank you so much for your
Insight David I really appreciate it all
right Gabe from Louisiana great to hear
from you